Imagine boarding a plane without security checks, turbulence or even ticketing.
And there's more than just peanuts for dinner.
Since last November, an entrepreneur in Taipei has been providing this sort of service...
...to people who love to fly.
Packing in the passengers, the restaurant looks and almost functions like an airliner...
...but sells a full menu's worth of Western food.
Diners at A380 in-flight kitchen sit in soft speckled blue seats...
...graced with white napkins under oval-shaped windows.
Locked white baggage compartments hang overhead.
Waitresses dressed as flight attendants take meal orders for filet mignon or waffles...
...as well as the customary fish and chicken standbys.
Customers say they love the in-flight experience.
This restaurant looks like a real airplane.
It's fun and amusing.
We come here often, this is quite special.
My daughter likes going on airplanes, but we don't have that many opportunities to,...
...so coming here gives her that experience.
While airline food doesn't usually taste good,...
...this restaurant has the food problem fixed on the ground.
Initially we saw A380, the luxury Airbus,...
...and wished to combine the food on the ground and the flight experience.
We had the concept of dining in a passenger compartment, then came up with the menu.
After the interior renovation, we extended the idea to in-flight services.
The diner decor cost about $200,000.